Capcom right now are doing so well
they're making actually very very good
remix consistently across the board top
tier remix in fact I would argue that
they have single-handedly revitalized
the survival horror genre by making
other Publishers go wait those do sell
when there was a period of time
EA shut down the studio who make
Dead Space because they were like nobody
cares about these the sales that they've
gotten across the board for Resident
Evil almost every single one of those
games has been fantastic recently Street
Fighter absolutely fantastic top of that
game all the games that they're making
are getting incredibly High review
scores right now and at the same time
they're still making new IP like except
Primal which is weird and creative
they're not just remaking the same
Dragon's Dogma 2 has got to be one of
the most anticipated games of the year
and couldn't be more different to
everything else on that roster obviously
Devil May Cry like I just feel like
Capcom right now are not getting
anywhere near as much credit as they
deserve